Yolanda and I were connected for
reparations website I was interested in
donating a piano to a family that might
find a need for it
[Music]
our daughter nevaeh is very musically
inclined well you know we don't have
twenty-five thousand dollars to get a
brand-new baby grand in the house so I
feel excited at all these pyramids the
idea of reparations to me is more of hey
if you have the privilege share
[Music]
if you are privileged and your black
offer your privilege to someone who's
disadvantaging black or white whatever
it is it's supposed to be about the
privileged handing over to the
disadvantage when the via walked in and
saw the piano it definitely was a very
emotional moment for me I just stunned
I'm gonna play out on this a lot
you